that was the crowd that greeted
conservative writer ben shapiro as he
was attempting to give a speech at the
los angeles campus of California State
University inside the lecture hall where
he had been invited it went like this
watch folks if you're watching on the
live stream the waves of students that
you see entering right now are being
sneaked in because in America in 2016
you have to use the back door if you
want to participate in free speech you
get to block the front door if you're a
member of the left and this is how it's
written you will and there it is gang
[Music]
guess what you know what they're not
going to stop us
[Applause]
ben shapiro is editor-in-chief at daily
wire.com been great to see you so they
invited you there this young group and
the university was not happy about it
initially tried to stop it one professor
in particular was ripping down the
fliers threatening students for posting
them but you showed up
take it from there yeah well the
president of the university attempted to
cancel the speech and I told him to
screw himself I was coming anyway
because that was a violation of free
speech rights about an hour and a half
before I was scheduled to come to campus
I don't know if there didn't try to
arrest me or something he backed down
and he said well he'll hold the event
we'll make sure there's enough security
that it's safe
I started getting messages on my texts
and through Twitter that there was
violence going down that there was a
huge crowd by the time we got there
there were helicopters cops everywhere
every single entrance and exit except
for one had been barricaded and blocked
by the students the police were doing
nothing to actually move the students
and the protesters that people who
wanted to here could get in and by the
time I got in I had to be escorted in
not only by my own security but by an
arm's coterie of uniformed police
officers and they were sneaking all of
the students in four at a time through a
back door the the protesters hadn't yet
discovered public university they don't
understand anything about First
Amendment which is the answer to speech
you do not like is not less speech it's
more speech you don't shut down the
initial speech you you have your own
events you offer your own viewpoints but
they were rows deep threatening you
people were getting pushed around and
the people were who wanted to get in to
see you we're getting stopped by the
cops apparently you say under directions
from the University so basically what I
say is that the police officers were
doing nothing they've been told by the
university to not move any of the
protesters who had locked arms and we're
blocking off the door so nobody could
get through and there's plenty of video
on Instagram and YouTube of these people
who are attempting to just get in to
listen being pushed around by members of
the audience or screaming them cursing
at them pushing them assaulting them a
reporter from Breitbart was assaulted
three times a man who was disabled with
nerve damage he was assaulted by folks
who were who are protesting it it truly
was the fascists left at work I take it
no apology was forthcoming no of course
not the only apology they wanted was an
apology for me and then from the
for allowing me to speak in the first
place again I'm a California taxpayer I
pay for all these dolts to go to college
here and all these professors to protest
and and try to tear down flyers but you
know this is a blatant violation of free
speech principles and more than that
it's it's just more evidence that there
is a movement within the left a very
hardcore fascist movement within the
left to shut down speech that they
disagree with and to punish physically
people who they don't like and that's
why at the very end I turned to the
students and I said do you want to go
out there and confront some of these
protesters and I was told by the police
officers if you do that there could
actually be a riot they said we don't
have the capacity to protect you or the
other students and I'm talking about ten
uniformed officers and at the time who
were scheduled to protect me
professor Robert wide w Eid II when
people were placing flyers on the board
he apparently went out and tore down the
flyers called campus security and called
the students fascists who wanted to hear
you speak Ben thank you for being here
thanks so much
taking your thoughts on that
facebook.com slash the Kelly file up now